aux Philippines vont être extradés vers
le port de boussane aborde un
gigantesque cargo les forces de l'ordre
sécurisées un navire de près de 58000
tonnes un colosse des mers le frontière
Titon
[Musique]
va prendre la main sur cette opération
le frontière est maintenant sous nos
commandements au travail
mais écoutez bien je me fous
complètement de vos noirs il y a aucune
caméra
si vous tenez à rentrer au Versailles en
un seul morceau je vous conseille de ne
pas vous faire remarquer soyez sage
est-ce que l'un d'entre vous veut aller
en Corée
[Musique]
ce bateau m'appartient maintenant
est-ce que vous savez piloter ce navire
[Musique]